you start off your newsletter with this
whole idea around like the fed
announcing uh the tapering and then what
we're seeing in the uh futures perpetual
funding rate so walk us through this do
you do you mind if we start with the
first chart like dude we can start with
whatever you want this is your show now
what we're looking at here is a just
some price levels and then b bollinger
bands with the wick high high time frame
indicator over it just is looking for
these volatility squeezes so you're
essentially looking at where price is
getting compressed and aka where
volatility slows down and we're primed
up for an expansion because
consolidation leads to expansion
expansion leads to consolidation um and
and so what we're looking at here is
this indicator identifies when we're
getting ready to have one of these
squeezes um and then the bands are these
are bollinger bands i think almost
anybody who does ta are
is familiar with bollinger bands but
essentially they're looking at the
standard deviation from price and um you
know by definition when price is at the
bottom of the bands price is relatively
low when it's at the top it's relatively
high um and then so yeah what we're
looking at here is these previous three
volatility squeezes we had one in april
um one at the bottom of summer and then
the third one in september what i want
to point out here is a couple things a
the amount of exactly how much time they
take to play out kind of varies like if
you look in april it took you know a
good week or two for that to play out
versus over the summer it took about
four or five days right and then the one
over september in september took about a
week um and then the other thing i
wanted to point out was
oftentimes these squeezes break out in
one direction to grab liquidity from the
breakout traders before going in the
opposite way
and so if like if you look here for
example in april we broke out above the
bands so it looked like oh we're
squeezing to the upside right
trapped all the traders that are looking
to you know trade that breakout you know
market makers grab the liquidity or
whales grab the liquidity and then we go
the other direction same thing over
summer would look like we were breaking
out to the downside grab that liquidity
and then we flipped to the upside
and so right now we're sitting smack dab
in the middle between both bands at
least at the time of writing um but you
know that's just something to keep in
mind if you're if you're watching this
moving forward when you start to look at
how the underlying
kind of fundamentals are looking the
first thing that you wrote about was
that uh bitcoin futures perpetual
funding rate how much before we kind of
go into what exactly that's telling us
how much do you look at like the price
and things like bollinger bands etc uh
being driven by these underlying
fundamentals or do you think that
there's some reverse uh element that
people are actually reacting to price
like are they driving price or reacting
to price in your opinion um when you're
actually looking at kind of like a macro
analysis of bitcoin well it's both i
mean you know some people sit in like
the you know
efficient market hypothesis and they say
everything's priced in you know then
there's people like you know i'm reading
george soros book alchemy of finance
right now and he's talking about
essentially you know people aren't
making decisions based off of what's
best for them they're making decisions
off of what they perceive to be the best
decision for them to make and so like
with that being said i think you know
when we're talking about like news i
mean people are just reacting to what
they think is the appropriate reaction
to the news not necessarily what's the
correct reaction to news um as far as
the fundamentals go i think you're kind
of are you like implying like like on
chain when you're when you're saying
fundamentals correct okay cool yeah i
mean so i look at it two ways
when we have like we're talking like
supply and those kind of things like
supply getting locked up that those
things or supply you know becoming
liquid those kinds of things tend to be
leading indicators but at the same time
price can affect uh you know market
participant behavior um you know if we
start to see like
prolonged downtrend you know people that
were
previously really strong hodlers you
know they may you know let let's say
someone bought in
five months ago right and they've now
become a long-term holder they bought in
now they'll be in june and so they've
held since june
you know that
you know they've held through the bottom
of the of the bear but they pretty much
like you know just experienced up only
um and so then you know let's say we
start to reverse pretty heavily well
then you know those what were previously
long-term holders they may say oh well
forget this right like okay i'm out
and because they were just expecting you
know some some major reversal off of the
off of the summer lows and so what i'm
trying to get at is just like
a lot of times on chain is a leading
indicator but there are certain
occasions where you know fundamentals
are are affected by price um or if you
have news events too you know you can
you can see the reaction of that stuff
in the data so it's like oftentimes i
don't really look at news too much i
mean i i do watch news you know
like major headlines i have like like
alerts on like market watch but
generally speaking the way i kind of
think through that is
you can you can really get caught up in
um
your biases around like news and and you
know it's one thing to keep up with the
bitcoin market but then to try to like
become a global macro you know expert
like that's like you know you're just
not gonna be able to do that and so what
i what i look for is what is what is
what are the market participants
actually doing in reaction to the news
and then i can then i kind of use that
as a way to gauge like okay
is you know is the market completely
changing behavior based off this news
well you know maybe that's something
actually serious versus you know we've
got china banning bitcoin for the 20
million time no one cares right and you
can see that in the data so i i would
say like
i i tend to look at the data to gauge
what the reaction is from you know from
the news or whatever i think that's a
great way to uh to kind of frame it as
to how you look at it